hot breath is there any advice
um you've gotten from her from getting
to work with her so much that you just
kind of will never forget
um i mean at this point
you know there are personal life lessons
that i learn and we discuss and share
and her experiences i would say
you know this isn't necessarily
something new but
the idea that all of this is it's a lot
it's it's not a
it's not a sprint it's a long it's a
long road
you know so you have to keep that in
mind with your ups and downs
i think that's something she's good at
reminding me of
that um you know you're gonna have
disappointments and things
that you fall short and failures and
you're here to stay and i think that's a
fear that you have for a long time
that you fail and you're gone but it's
like
they gave what's that woman's name and
haiti like three television shows like
certain people get many many chances and
i think
that does it just because you might not
be a as well known of a writer doesn't
mean that you won't have more than one
chance to
you know it's not it's not as make or
break as
that phrase that is his major
break you know it's like it's the same
thing like when people say
um this is your big break it's like
i've been breaking for the last seven
years
i guess that was my performance
yeah he was on here a week or
two ago and he had talked about like
netflix not picking him up
and he was like you got to be in a
wheelchair like you know he had a funny
joke about it but it's like
[Laughter]